okay so what's this amazing symbol pi
well pi if i can draw the circle
reasonably well
is uh the ratio
of the circumference of the circle
to its diameter
so that's what pi is and we all know
that it's 3.1415
nine
two and now i'm struggling i think it's
if you get this i think it's a very good
test of geekiness i think if you can
only write pi down to uh
six significant figures you're not
really very much of a geek but if you
can go four or five beyond this this
increases your level of geekiness
a lot of respect for you but you are a
gig i hope not
why is it important well if you're uh
making a circular building it's pretty
important for knowing bricks about how
many bricks you've got to use um and for
all sorts of geometrical problems i mean
pi just doesn't come in for the
problem of the circle it gives us the 4
pi r squared gives us the surface area
of the sphere and four thirds pi r cubed
gives us the volume of the sphere so
those are very useful numbers to know
that when we're doing problems in
physics and engineering in your normal
work yeah how often do you use pi oh i
should think i use it every day two or
three times a day probably yeah and so
there are many problems in physics and
astronomy and so on uh
that in which we're dealing with things
like spheres so the proton for example
is about one of the smallest
spheres that we can measure to any level
of precision and understand we
understand it very well and it's charged
and the electric field lines come out of
it so we need to know the geometry of
the circle that encloses the surface of
of something like a proton and of course
the the
the moon and the earth and the sun most
of the planets to a good approximation
are also spheres and uh
when we're doing
problems about
with them atmospheric problems and
things like this again the size of the
sphere is really important so it crops
up in just about every problem in
science
i'm a physicist and it's mathematicians
who've really been fascinated and worked
for a long time on pi and thought about
it and
i
guess one of the things we learned in
school that to a reasonable
approximation the reason approximation
this number is actually 22 upon 7. now
it doesn't give us the ratio of the
circumference to the diameter that
accurately but it's a pretty pretty good
approximation if you put that into a
calculator you can compare how it what
its value is to to the
to the precise value of of pi but
mathematicians have been fascinated
at the prospect of trying to to express
pi as a sum
of
integers or fractions of integers and
there are various ways of doing this and
i think one of the most remarkable ones
uh
is this
that pi by 4 now pi is 3.14 so pi by 4
was around about 0.8 and it turns out
that pi by 4 can be written
in terms of an infinite series and i'll
see if i can get this right so it's 1
minus one-third
plus one-fifth
minus one-seventh
plus one-ninth
on and on and on to infinity so we've
got an infinite series this infinite
series here is giving us this value of
pi if we go on for long enough adding
more and more terms we'll get the value
of pi where these numbers how can i
remember this so easily well i start off
with one and i know that one is bigger
than pi by four so i'll take off uh a
third uh and that's a that's an odd
integer but that name makes the number
too small so i now add a fifth and then
i'll take off a seventh and then i'll
add another one over an odd integer and
so on i'll add infinitum now i brought
along a couple of other series i mean
there are there are
other series that people like euler and
so on have developed and i think i can
just remember these as well but as they
take a bit of time to write that this is
another rather beautiful series
a pi squared which is about 10
but if you want to calculate pi you can
do this with pi squared divided by 6 is
given by 1 upon the square of the first
integer and then 1 upon 2 squared plus 1
upon 3 squared again up to infinity so
it's another one of these infinite
series
and this is another one for pi by 2
where now instead of adding an infinite
series of terms we take here a numerator
which goes on multi multiplied forever
so we've got 2 times 2 times 4 times 4
times 6 times 6. in the numerator and
the denominator has got denominators got
3 times 3 times 5 times 5
times 7 pi 7 and both of those are going
on for infinity and that gives you pi by
2 which is of course pi by 2 being
the
angle of a
right angle triangle so that angle there
of course is the famous pi by 2.